ah [ __ ] goat hello Anton France this
is Alexa Chung
we're here with necks in fashion and
we're gonna play a game of first
impressions with Tyler you go tonight
oh me too don't worry about it great
Disney kind of character as well
sometimes animal oh hey you stay oh my
gosh honey is it hi
don't come here leave that spray don't
come near me with that spa that crusty
the cow cook you don't watch those
YouTube clips no that's a sheep goat
scream okay okay oh I saw this on TV
doesn't Oh Strictly Come Dancing and
they've got really funky haircuts like a
bowl cut mine it's a mine oh my god is
it an animal
it's a sloth yeah okay great I love that
you take funky hair go to the barber
right you're like oh can we take a break
I need a [ __ ] me
except I just walked out I know now it's
being really nice a bit like how you do
it pretty much is it we were at a
Victoria Park and Becca Victoria party
Doria by the Victoria bounds so do she
she gasped all kind of shriek from a
distance as I walked by and then she
ducked down into tears like how do you
get your hair Barris and I was like yes
8335 with TV you could have have to turn
your and self embarrass me yeah you're a
clown I do it the ocean and we look them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god Chandler bank Janice
we shot put our pinkies up that's not
what we actually do just a posh person
the Queen ultimate person I've got
incredibly dry hair that I need to
moisturize but I'm a magician young
person magician version oh no you must
eat you must read your books what oh
well let's go and play Quidditch
I've got soft dry hair oh ha ha
conditioner yeah I think she's I've
never seen I don't know I realized
crackly honey Jonathan I I this week
I've eaten three cakes and I've taken to
date on a date with three separate men
and I persuade my really large knickers
and I'm quite sure that our American
doing yeah yeah thank you
that's exactly right feel that now you
have it that was first impressions for
Tyler I've been Alexa Chung he's tried
to beat an France and other people
thanks for watching thanks so much guys
that really liked you that was that woke
us up and also are you really appreciate
this hot box you put it in it's quite
welcome
[Music]
you